Oil sands operations contribute significant carbon emissions in Canada. So the six largest companies have teamed up to make strides on the path to NetZero. Investing in technology and innovation. Already cut emissions in average 22% per barrel. Working with governments to create and protect jobs. Developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our NetZero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at pathwaysalliance.ca
加拿大的油砂开采产生了大量的碳排放。因此，六家最大的公司联手合作，在实现净零排放的道路上迈出步伐。通过投资技术和创新，每桶原油的排放量平均已经减少了22%。我们正与政府合作，创造并保护就业岗位，同时开发全球最大的碳捕集与封存设施之一。我们的净零计划正在实施中，并在多个途径上取得了进展。请访问pathwaysalliance.ca了解我们的行动计划。
The gatehouse was a secluded mansion on the edge of the new forest in Hampshire, England. It was 8.30pm on the 1st of September 1986. The residents had just finished dinner and were about to enjoy dessert. And that's when three men wearing stocking masks and armed with a shotgun and pickaxes burst into the dining room. The gatehouse was located in Fortingbridge, a town in Hampshire, England on the edge of the new forest. It was originally an old farmhouse that was converted into a large mansion. It was situated at the end of a long winding driveway on a large site of 14 acres. Buried behind trees in what was a very quiet and secluded spot.
“门房”（The Gatehouse）是一座位于英国汉普郡新森林边缘的隐蔽宅邸。那是1986年9月1日晚上8点30分。住户们刚吃完晚餐，正准备享用甜点。就在这时，三名戴着丝袜面罩、手持猎枪和鹤嘴锄的男子闯入了餐厅。“门房”位于英国汉普郡福丁布里奇镇，坐落在新森林的边缘。它原本是一座老农舍，后来被改建成了一座大宅邸。它坐落在一条长长蜿蜒的车道尽头，占地14英亩，掩映在树木之后，是一个非常安静且隐蔽的地方。
The couple that lived there were Joseph and Hilda Cleaver. They were quiet yet sociable people well liked in the community. Joseph Cleaver was 82 years old, a successful retired publisher. His wife Hilda was the same age and was confined to a wheelchair after suffering a stroke. They originally used the house as a holiday home before eventually moving in full time when Joseph retired. On the 1st of September 1986, Joseph and Hilda Cleaver were enjoying the company of their son Tom Cleaver, 49 years old, and his wife Wendy Cleaver, 46 years old. Tom and Wendy were helping out as the living cook and handyman had just been fired. So Tom was looking after his elderly parents, keeping an eye on things until replacements could be found.
住在那里的夫妇是约瑟夫·克利弗（Joseph Cleaver）和希尔达·克利弗（Hilda Cleaver）。他们是安静但善于交际的人，在社区里很受欢迎。约瑟夫·克利弗82岁，是一位成功的退休出版商。他的妻子希尔达同岁，因中风而不得不坐轮椅。他们最初将这所房子用作度假屋，后来在约瑟夫退休后搬进去全职居住。1986年9月1日，约瑟夫和希尔达·克利弗正在与他们的儿子汤姆·克利弗（49岁）及其妻子温迪·克利弗（46岁）共度时光。由于刚解雇了住家厨师和杂工，汤姆和温迪正在帮忙照看，直到找到替代人选。
Desert had just been served by their elderly housekeeper Margaret Murphy, 70 years old. She had worked for the family for 50 years. The Cleavers kept a strict routine when it came to dinner. It was always served at 8pm on the dot and everybody was expected to be dressed appropriately for the occasion. It was about 8.30pm when the doors to the dining room suddenly burst open and three masked men brandishing a shotgun and pickaxes entered. The intruders screamed at Hilda, Wendy and Margaret to take off their jewellery. Tom and Joseph were ordered to put their wallets and cash on the table. The five were then forced to the upstairs master bedroom where they were tied up.
甜点刚由他们70岁的老管家玛格丽特·墨菲（Margaret Murphy）端上来。她为这个家庭工作了50年。克利弗一家在晚餐方面有着严格的作息。晚餐总是准时在晚上8点供应，每个人都被要求穿着得体。大约晚上8点30分，餐厅的大门突然被撞开，三名戴着面罩、挥舞着猎枪和鹤嘴锄的男子闯了进来。入侵者尖叫着命令希尔达、温迪和玛格丽特摘下首饰。汤姆和约瑟夫被命令将钱包和现金放在桌子上。随后，这五人被强行带到楼上的主卧室并被捆绑起来。
Some left on the floor, some left on the bed. Hilda Cleaver was tied up to her wheelchair. The intruders then spent over an hour ransacking the house. They collected together a pile of guns that Joseph had in his gun cabinet. They also grabbed a TV and video recorder, a stash of alcohol and other items. They got 90lbs cash from the men's wallets. The intruders then started ripping paintings off the walls and using the pickaxes to strike into the walls. They were looking for a hidden safe.
有些人被留在地板上，有些人被留在床上。希尔达·克利弗被绑在她的轮椅上。入侵者随后花了一个多小时洗劫了房子。他们收集了约瑟夫枪柜里的一堆枪支。他们还抢走了一台电视机、录像机、一批酒精饮料和其他物品。他们从男人的钱包里抢走了90英镑现金。随后，入侵者开始撕下墙上的画作，并用鹤嘴锄猛击墙壁。他们在寻找一个隐藏的保险箱。
They searched everywhere but couldn't locate it. Frustrated at not being able to find the safe, the intruders stormed back upstairs. At 10.30am the next day, the 2nd of September 1986, the gatehouse cleaner Nellie Taylor and gardener Edgar Stubbings arrived for work. They were both alarmed at the sight of smoke coming out of the upstairs windows. They cautiously entered the home and discovered that it had been torn apart. The dining table was still set with the unfinished dessert still there, but everything else was a mess. The cleaver's pet poodle was whimpering. The dog had been badly injured. It was in such a bad way that it later had to be put down.
他们搜遍了每一个角落，但没能找到。由于找不到保险箱而感到沮丧，入侵者冲回了楼上。第二天，即1986年9月2日上午10点30分，“门房”的清洁工内莉·泰勒（Nellie Taylor）和园丁埃德加·斯塔宾斯（Edgar Stubbings）来上班。他们都被楼上窗户冒出的烟雾惊到了。他们小心翼翼地进入屋内，发现里面一片狼藉。餐桌上还摆着没吃完的甜点，但其他一切都乱七八糟。克利弗家的宠物贵宾犬在呜咽。那只狗受了重伤，伤势严重，后来不得不被安乐死。
A feeling of dread came over Edgar. He picked up the phone to call the police, but there was nothing for silence. The lines had been cut. The cleavers had two other dogs that could be heard scratching at a door and whimpering upstairs. Nellie and Edgar walked upstairs, opened the door and found Wendy Cleaver, dead. She had been taken from the master bedroom into a separate bedroom. They found the nearby master bedroom was still glowing from a fire that had been lit. That is where the smoke was coming from. It was still too hot to enter.
一种恐惧感笼罩了埃德加。他拿起电话报警，但电话里一片死寂。线路被切断了。克利弗家还有另外两只狗，可以听到它们在楼上的门后抓挠和呜咽。内莉和埃德加走上楼，打开门，发现了温迪·克利弗的尸体。她被从主卧室带到了另一间卧室。他们发现附近的主卧室里还有火光，那是有人纵火留下的。烟雾就是从那里冒出来的。里面太热了，无法进入。
Edgar and Nellie ran from the house and drove to the local police station to raise the alarm. The crime scene was examined by scene of crime officer Detective Constable Malcolm Slaughter. The first thing he noticed was that there was unburnt fire lighter scattered throughout the entire house. Whoever was responsible had obviously intended to burn it down completely. He found that the gun cabinet had been emptied and two double barrel shotguns, a single barrel shotgun and a .22 rifle were missing, along with 12 boxes of ammunition. The cleaver's cocktail cabinet had been emptied and a large amount of spirits had been taken. Signs that the intruders were hunting for hidden safe were clear throughout the house. Detectives immediately thought the scene was the work of at least two men, possibly more.
埃德加和内莉跑出房子，开车前往当地警察局报警。犯罪现场由现场勘查警官马尔科姆·斯劳特（Malcolm Slaughter）侦探警员进行检查。他注意到的第一件事是，整个房子里散落着未燃尽的引火物。显然，肇事者打算将其彻底烧毁。他发现枪柜已被清空，两支双管猎枪、一支单管猎枪和一支.22口径步枪不见了，还有12盒弹药。克利弗家的酒柜也被清空，大量烈酒被拿走。入侵者在屋内搜寻隐藏保险箱的迹象非常明显。侦探们立即认为这起案件是至少两名、甚至更多人所为。
Joseph, Hilda and Tom Cleaver and Margaret Murphy were found dead in the upstairs master bedroom where the fire had been lit. Two gallons of petrol were poured across the curtains, carpet, bed and over the victims themselves. A lit fire lighter was then thrown in and a ball of flames erupted. Prior to the fire being lit, Wendy Cleaver had been dragged out of the master bedroom, sexually assaulted, then strangled. The killers had tried to burn down the entire house to destroy all evidence. But what they didn't know was that the gatehouse was rebuilt from a 19th century farmhouse. It was rebuilt in the 1940s, when timber was a scarce commodity because of the Second World War. So mostly concrete was used during the building process.
约瑟夫、希尔达、汤姆·克利弗和玛格丽特·墨菲被发现死在纵火的楼上主卧室里。两加仑汽油被泼在窗帘、地毯、床上以及受害者身上。随后，一个点燃的引火物被扔了进去，瞬间燃起大火。在纵火前，温迪·克利弗被从主卧室拖出，遭到性侵，然后被勒死。凶手试图烧毁整栋房子以销毁所有证据。但他们不知道的是，“门房”是根据19世纪的农舍重建的。它在20世纪40年代重建，当时由于第二次世界大战，木材是稀缺商品。因此，建筑过程中主要使用了混凝土。
That's why the structure of the house remained intact and there was very little sign of the fire from the outside. The fire pretty much contained itself in the master bedroom. It looked to be a robbery, but why had the victims been so savagely murdered? Police felt it was one of two reasons. The victims had seen their killers' faces during the attack, or they already knew who they were, which would explain why there were no signs of forced entry. Police started looking into the background of the victims. Was there anything there that could shed any light on this crime? They didn't come up with much.
这就是为什么房子的结构保持完好，从外面看几乎没有火灾的迹象。火势基本上被控制在主卧室里。这看起来像是一起抢劫案，但为什么受害者会被如此残忍地杀害？警方认为有两个原因之一：受害者在袭击中看到了凶手的脸，或者他们已经认识凶手，这解释了为什么没有强行闯入的迹象。警方开始调查受害者的背景。那里有什么能揭示这起罪行的线索吗？他们并没有发现太多。
But while searching Joseph Cleaver's study, they found a newspaper advertisement he had placed seeking a living cook and handyman at the gatehouse. The advertisement was placed only two months earlier. They also found a reference letter attached for a couple who applied for the job, George and Fiona Stevenson. Police questioned the cleaner Nellie and gardener Edgar about the advertisement, and they confirmed that the positions had been filled by the couple police located a reference letter for, George and Fiona. They landed the job and moved into a small cottage located on the estate grounds in late July, only a few months earlier. But they only lasted a few weeks. George Stevenson beat his wife regularly, and one night Fiona ran out of the cottage to escape his attack and sought refuge in Brigade House.
但在搜查约瑟夫·克利弗的书房时，他们发现了他刊登的一则报纸广告，招聘住家厨师和杂工。这则广告是两个月前刊登的。他们还发现了一封附带的推荐信，申请人是一对夫妇，乔治·史蒂文森（George Stevenson）和菲奥娜·史蒂文森（Fiona Stevenson）。警方询问了清洁工内莉和园丁埃德加关于广告的事，他们证实职位确实由警方找到推荐信的那对夫妇乔治和菲奥娜填补了。他们在7月下旬，即几个月前，得到了这份工作并搬进了庄园内的一间小屋。但他们只待了几周。乔治·史蒂文森经常殴打妻子，一天晚上，菲奥娜为了逃避他的攻击跑出小屋，在“门房”寻求庇护。
The housekeeper Margaret Murphy let Fiona in and hid her from her husband. Fiona ran off the next day. She had only been married to George Stevenson for nine months. They married two weeks after meeting each other in what was a whirlwind romance. When Joseph Cleaver learned of this incident, he was disgusted and immediately sacked Stevenson. Fiona had already taken off and her whereabouts were unknown. All this happened only a few weeks before the murder, and it was about the only thing police found that could have relevance. Police started looking into George Stevenson.
管家玛格丽特·墨菲让菲奥娜进来，并将她藏起来躲避丈夫。菲奥娜第二天就跑了。她和乔治·史蒂文森结婚才九个月。他们在相识两周后就结婚了，这是一场闪电般的恋情。当约瑟夫·克利弗得知这件事后，他感到非常厌恶，立即解雇了史蒂文森。菲奥娜已经离开，下落不明。这一切发生在谋杀案发生前几周，这是警方发现的唯一可能与案件有关的事情。警方开始调查乔治·史蒂文森。
George had done several stints in jail. He had convictions for burglary, fraud, theft, assault, drugs and firearms offences. He also had a conviction for resisting arrest. He sprayed a police officer who was trying to arrest him with tear gas. Detectives checked the reference letter and found it had been written by a couple in Bournemouth on the southern coast of England, about a 30 minute drive away from the murder scene. They quickly paid that couple a visit to try and get a bit more background on George Stevenson. They almost couldn't believe it when they were invited into the couple's home and they saw a TV and video recorder, matching no stolen from the gatehouse.
乔治曾多次入狱。他有入室盗窃、欺诈、盗窃、袭击、毒品和枪支犯罪的前科。他还有拒捕的前科。他曾向一名试图逮捕他的警察喷洒催泪瓦斯。侦探们检查了那封推荐信，发现它是伯恩茅斯（英格兰南海岸，距离案发现场约30分钟车程）的一对夫妇写的。他们很快拜访了那对夫妇，试图了解更多关于乔治·史蒂文森的背景。当他们被邀请进屋，看到一台电视机和录像机，与从“门房”被盗的物品相符时，他们简直不敢相信。
Police interviewed them extensively. They said the last they spoke with George Stevenson was on Monday morning, the day of the murder. Their TV had just broken and Stevenson asked if they wanted a new one, which they said yes they did. After a bit more general chitchat, Stevenson left. The couple woke up the next morning, Tuesday the 2nd of September, to find the TV and recorder on their front porch. They never saw Stevenson, but he had obviously come through for them. This information, combined with the knowledge Stevenson had been fired from the gatehouse only weeks before the murder, was enough to make him their prime suspect. Stevenson's wife Fiona had also contacted police as soon as she read about the murders.
警方对他们进行了广泛的询问。他们说最后一次与乔治·史蒂文森交谈是在周一早上，即谋杀案发生的那天。他们的电视机刚坏，史蒂文森问他们是否想要一台新的，他们说想要。在进行了一些闲聊后，史蒂文森离开了。这对夫妇第二天早上（9月2日星期二）醒来时，发现电视机和录像机就在前廊上。他们没见到史蒂文森，但他显然为他们办到了。这些信息，加上史蒂文森在谋杀案发生前几周被“门房”解雇的事实，足以使他成为头号嫌疑人。史蒂文森的妻子菲奥娜在读到谋杀案报道后也立即联系了警方。
She had no doubt her husband, who she was still hiding from, was to blame. With that, Stevenson's picture was on every TV and newspaper in the country, and every police officer was on the lookout for him. He was considered armed and extremely dangerous. Stevenson had grown up in Coventry, England, about a two and a half hour drive away from the murder scene. Police checked that area extensively and they were in luck. Stevenson had hired a vehicle, a Red Rover 213, only days before the killing, but he didn't pay the deposit for the hire car. That was paid by another man, George Daly, also from Coventry. Police always felt the crime was committed by more than one person. Now they had a second suspect.
她毫不怀疑她仍在躲避的丈夫是罪魁祸首。随之，史蒂文森的照片出现在全国所有的电视和报纸上，每位警察都在寻找他。他被认为持有武器且极其危险。史蒂文森在英格兰考文垂长大，距离案发现场约两个半小时车程。警方对该地区进行了广泛搜查，他们很幸运。史蒂文森在杀人案发生前几天租了一辆车，一辆红色罗孚213，但他没有支付租车押金。押金是由另一名同样来自考文垂的男子乔治·戴利（George Dailey）支付的。警方一直认为犯罪是由不止一人实施的。现在他们有了第二个嫌疑人。
It didn't take long for George Stevenson to see his own face staring back at him from the TV screen. He couldn't hide his shock. It was only days after the murder. He immediately got on the phone to police in Hampshire. To their surprise, Stevenson said he was going to hand himself in. He wanted to clear his name. But before giving himself up, he had a night out on the town, doing a pub crawl around Brockenhurst, about a 30 minute drive away from the murder scene. On this pub crawl, he carried a copy of a newspaper under his arm, with his face plastered on the front page. But he had changed his appearance, shaving his mustache off and cutting his hair. Stevenson chatted up two girls in one of the pubs and went back to the campsite they were staying at.
乔治·史蒂文森没过多久就从电视屏幕上看到了自己的脸。他无法掩饰自己的震惊。那是在谋杀案发生几天后。他立即给汉普郡警方打了电话。令他们惊讶的是，史蒂文森说他要自首。他想洗清自己的罪名。但在自首之前，他在布罗肯赫斯特（距离案发现场约30分钟车程）附近进行了一次酒吧巡游。在这次巡游中，他腋下夹着一份报纸，头版上印着他的脸。但他改变了外貌，刮掉了胡子，剪短了头发。史蒂文森在其中一家酒吧搭讪了两名女孩，并回到了她们居住的露营地。
They drank together until about 2am. Stevenson then left the campsite, walked to a nearby pay phone and rang detectives to come and get him. In the meantime, police were also honing in on the man who paid the deposit on Stevenson's hire car, George Dailey. Police questioned Ruth Smith, who lived with George. She gave a statement that Stevenson and George Dailey returned home at 3am the night of the murders. They walked in with gums and boxes of ammunition. And they had a third person with them, George's brother, John Dailey. They had a large collection of spirits, which they used to have a very loud drinking session until dawn. Not only that, Ruth described the panic in George and John Dailey when Stevenson's face appeared on TV, wanted for the murders. When they saw that, George and John quickly carried the guns out of the house.
他们一起喝酒直到凌晨2点左右。史蒂文森随后离开露营地，走到附近的公用电话亭，打电话给侦探来抓他。与此同时，警方也在锁定支付史蒂文森租车押金的人——乔治·戴利。警方询问了与乔治同居的露丝·史密斯（Ruth Smith）。她作证说，史蒂文森和乔治·戴利在谋杀案当晚凌晨3点回到家。他们带着枪支和弹药箱走进来。他们还有第三个人，乔治的兄弟约翰·戴利（John Dailey）。他们带回了大量烈酒，并一直喝到天亮。不仅如此，露丝还描述了当史蒂文森因谋杀案被通缉的消息出现在电视上时，乔治和约翰的恐慌。看到消息后，乔治和约翰迅速将枪支搬出了房子。
After receiving this information, George and John Dailey were quickly taken into custody, around the same time Stevenson handed himself in. The trial for the three men commenced at Winchester Crown Court on the 6th of October 1987. All three men were charged with five counts of murder and one count of rape, as well as a robbery. All three pleaded not guilty to the charges, but John Dailey did plead guilty to the sexual assault of Wendy Cleaver. Police believed the motive for the attack was that George Stevenson wanted revenge for being sacked from his job, and he was jealous of the Cleaver's wealth and the lavish lifestyle. He was the ringleader. He knew it had to end in murder as he risked being identified. Even though he was wearing a mask, he feared he would be recognized from his voice and from his shape and build. Having worked at Brigade House, Stevenson was familiar with the dinner routine of the Cleavers, always sitting down to eat at precisely 8pm.
收到此信息后，乔治和约翰·戴利很快被拘留，大约在史蒂文森自首的同时。这三人的审判于1987年10月6日在温彻斯特刑事法庭开始。三人均被控五项谋杀罪、一项强奸罪以及一项抢劫罪。三人均不认罪，但约翰·戴利承认了对温迪·克利弗的性侵犯。警方认为袭击的动机是乔治·史蒂文森因被解雇而寻求报复，并且嫉妒克利弗一家的财富和奢华生活。他是主谋。他知道这必须以谋杀告终，因为他冒着被认出的风险。尽管他戴着面具，但他担心自己的声音、体型和身材会被认出来。曾在“门房”工作过的史蒂文森熟悉克利弗一家的晚餐习惯，总是准时在晚上8点坐下吃饭。
He was also familiar with the fact they left a front door key on the porch until 9pm every night. Getting into the house had been as simple as using that key to let themselves in. Stevenson and the Daileys arrived at 8.30pm that night. They had brought the petrol, firelighters, stocking masks and pickaxes with them, but they stole the shotgun from Joseph's gun cabinet before bursting into the dining room. Where Joseph stored his guns was another thing that Stevenson knew from his time working there. They were only expecting the housekeeper Margaret and Joseph and Hilda. They didn't know Tom and Wendy would also be present. And that they were only there helping out until Joseph and Hilda could find a suitable replacement for Stevenson and his wife Fiona. During his police interview, John Dailey admitted to the sexual assault of Wendy Cleaver.
他还熟悉他们每晚9点前都会在前廊留一把前门钥匙的事实。进入房子就像使用那把钥匙一样简单。史蒂文森和戴利兄弟当晚8点30分到达。他们随身携带了汽油、引火物、丝袜面罩和鹤嘴锄，但在闯入餐厅前，他们从约瑟夫的枪柜里偷走了猎枪。约瑟夫存放枪支的地方是史蒂文森在工作期间知道的另一件事。他们原本只预料到管家玛格丽特、约瑟夫和希尔达会在场。他们不知道汤姆和温迪也会在场。他们当时只是在那里帮忙，直到约瑟夫和希尔达能为史蒂文森和他的妻子菲奥娜找到合适的替代人选。在警方审讯中，约翰·戴利承认了对温迪·克利弗的性侵犯。
He says afterwards, Stevenson walked into the room with a knife and a piece of cloth. John Dailey's words. He didn't say anything. He just put them on the bed, but I knew what they were for, to kill her with. I thought it was just going to be a robbery. I thought we would get thousands. I never thought I would have to do anything. Stevenson became a suspect the same day the victims were found. There were no eyewitnesses, no forensics, no groundbreaking police work. They just simply followed up on a newspaper advertisement and a reference letter found in the study of the house. Stevenson wasn't shocked that his face was all over the papers and TV because he was innocent. He was shocked that they identified him so quickly. He couldn't believe it.
他说事后，史蒂文森拿着一把刀和一块布走进房间。这是约翰·戴利的原话。他什么也没说。他只是把它们放在床上，但我知道它们是用来做什么的，是用来杀她的。我以为这只是一次抢劫。我以为我们会得到几千英镑。我从没想过我必须做任何事。史蒂文森在受害者被发现的当天就成了嫌疑人。没有目击者，没有法医证据，没有开创性的警务工作。他们只是简单地跟进了在书房里发现的一则报纸广告和一封推荐信。史蒂文森并不惊讶他的脸出现在报纸和电视上，因为他是无辜的。他惊讶的是他们识别他的速度如此之快。他简直不敢相信。
He waited a day to hand himself in to give the Daileys time to hide the guns and dump the stolen property and to give himself time to concoct an alibi. In his police interview, Stevenson said he had driven to Bournemouth from Coventry about a two and a half hour drive. He saw two motorcycle gang members hitchhiking, so he decided to give them a lift. During the ride, he told the gang members about the gatehouse and the wealth of the cleavers and how Joseph had just fired him. So he says they must have used that information to commit the crime. But at the trial, Stevenson changed his story. No longer was he blaming motorcycle gang members he picked up while hitchhiking. He admitted making that up. His new story was that he went to the gatehouse with the Daileys, but he stayed outside and acted only as the getaway driver.
他等了一天才自首，是为了给戴利兄弟时间藏匿枪支和丢弃赃物，也为了给自己时间编造不在场证明。在警方审讯中，史蒂文森说他从考文垂开车到伯恩茅斯，大约两个半小时的车程。他看到两名摩托车帮派成员在搭便车，所以决定载他们一程。在车上，他告诉帮派成员关于“门房”和克利弗一家的财富，以及约瑟夫刚解雇他的事。所以他说他们一定利用了这些信息来犯罪。但在审判中，史蒂文森改变了说法。他不再指责他搭便车时载的摩托车帮派成员。他承认那是编造的。他的新说法是他和戴利兄弟去了“门房”，但他待在外面，只充当接应司机。
Stevenson had told the Daileys brothers about the guns and they wanted to go there and steal them. Stevenson denied being inside and denied there was any plan to kill anyone. He said, I would not have harmed them. They were lovely people. They had been good to me. The Daileys defense council was having none of it, saying the only way out for you now is to blame the Daileys brothers to try and save your own wretched skin. You are a man with no conscience. In George Daileys police interview, he says, After putting some stuff in the car, I went back into the house and it stank of petrol. Stevenson came down the stairs and said they were all dead.
史蒂文森告诉戴利兄弟关于枪支的事，他们想去那里偷走它们。史蒂文森否认进入屋内，也否认有任何杀人的计划。他说：“我不会伤害他们。他们是可爱的人。他们对我很好。”戴利兄弟的辩护律师对此不屑一顾，称：“你现在唯一的出路就是指责戴利兄弟，试图挽救你那卑劣的生命。你是一个没有良心的人。”在乔治·戴利的警方审讯中，他说：“把一些东西放进车里后，我回到屋里，里面充满了汽油味。史蒂文森走下楼梯说他们都死了。”
I thought they were just going to be left tied up, but he said we would have to burn the house. So I lit a fire lighter and threw it over the rail as I was on the stairs. There was no bang, it just went up in a big flash. Unfortunately, Joseph, Hilda, Tom and Margaret weren't dead when George Daileys threw that fire lighter. They died in the fire. George Daileys openly wept in the courtroom when this police interview was played. In relation to the sexual assault of Wendy Cleaver, George Daileys continued to deny his involvement. His account is that he walked in on Stevenson attacking her while still holding the shotgun in his hand.
“我以为他们只是会被绑起来，但他说是我们必须烧掉房子。所以我点燃了一个引火物，因为我在楼梯上，就把它扔过了栏杆。没有爆炸声，它只是瞬间燃起了一团大火。”不幸的是，当乔治·戴利扔下那个引火物时，约瑟夫、希尔达、汤姆和玛格丽特并没有死。他们死于火灾。当这段警方审讯录音在法庭上播放时，乔治·戴利公开痛哭。关于温迪·克利弗的性侵犯，乔治·戴利继续否认参与。他的说法是他走进房间时，史蒂文森正在袭击她，而他手里还拿着猎枪。
He said, I am telling the truth. I have nothing to lose because I'm going to be feeling guilty and sent to jail for life anyway. I'm not daft enough to think I'm going to get off this. Prosecutor David Elfer wasn't impressed with the defendants each trying to blame the other. In his closing address, he told the jury that all three men had plotted together and all three were as guilty as each other. He said, is there one of them that is not guilty of robbery? Is there one who is not guilty of rape? And is there one of them who was not party to the mayhem, carnage and murders that took place at the gatehouse?
他说：“我说的都是实话。我没什么可失去的，因为无论如何我都会感到内疚并被判终身监禁。我还没傻到认为我能逃脱惩罚。”检察官大卫·埃尔弗（David Elfer）对被告互相指责的行为并不买账。在结案陈词中，他告诉陪审团，这三个人是共谋，三个人都同样有罪。他说：“他们中有一个人没有犯抢劫罪吗？有一个人没有犯强奸罪吗？有一个人没有参与发生在‘门房’的混乱、屠杀和谋杀吗？”
The trial lasted 17 days. After deliberating for five and a half hours, the jury returned with a guilty verdict for Stevenson and George Daileys in relation to the sexual assault of Wendy Cleaver. Daileys had already played guilty. They didn't reach a verdict on the murders until the next day, the 28th of September 1987. George Stevenson, guilty for the murders of Joseph, Hilda, Tom and Margaret. He was acquitted for the murder of Wendy. He was sentenced to six life sentences for the four murders, rape and robbery. With a recommendation that he not be released for 25 years.
审判持续了17天。经过五个半小时的审议，陪审团对史蒂文森和乔治·戴利在温迪·克利弗性侵案上的指控作出了有罪判决。戴利已经认罪。直到第二天，即1987年9月28日，他们才对谋杀案达成裁决。乔治·史蒂文森被判谋杀约瑟夫、希尔达、汤姆和玛格丽特罪名成立。他被判谋杀温迪罪名不成立。他因四项谋杀、强奸和抢劫罪被判处六个终身监禁，并建议25年内不得假释。
The judge said, these murders were committed in circumstances of indescribable brutality and cruelty. You should know mercy and deserve none. Stevenson just shrugged his shoulders in response. He was 36 years old at the time. John Dailey was found guilty of all five murders and given seven life sentences for those and for the robbery and rape. He was 21 years old. Despite the combined 13 life sentences they received, the judge ruled that they be served concurrently, so all at the same time. Which is why Stevenson was eligible for release after 25 years.
法官说：“这些谋杀案是在难以形容的残暴和冷酷的情况下犯下的。你应该知道怜悯，但你不配得到任何怜悯。”史蒂文森对此只是耸了耸肩。他当时36岁。约翰·戴利被判五项谋杀罪全部成立，并因这些罪行以及抢劫和强奸罪被判处七个终身监禁。他当时21岁。尽管他们总共被判处13个终身监禁，但法官裁定这些刑期同时执行，即在同一时间服刑。这就是为什么史蒂文森在25年后有资格获得假释的原因。
The judge didn't make a minimum order of imprisonment for John Dailey. George Dailey was found not guilty of murder. The court accepting his story that he didn't know Joseph, Hilda, Tom and Margaret were still alive when he lit the fire. He was convicted of manslaughter instead. The judge was satisfied he didn't intentionally kill anyone, however he showed a reckless disregard for human life. He was sentenced to 22 years jail. He was 25 years old. While the Dailey's sentences were being read, Stevenson started steering at George Dailey. George Dailey tried to attack him, but they were separated by court officers.
法官没有对约翰·戴利设定最低刑期。乔治·戴利被判谋杀罪不成立。法庭接受了他的说法，即他在点火时不知道约瑟夫、希尔达、汤姆和玛格丽特还活着。他被改判过失杀人罪。法官确信他没有蓄意杀害任何人，但他表现出对人命的漠视。他被判处22年监禁。他当时25岁。当戴利的刑期被宣读时，史蒂文森开始盯着乔治·戴利看。乔治·戴利试图攻击他，但被法警分开了。
Stevenson then smiled at the jury as he was led away. There was a wall safe in the house that Stevenson and the Daileys missed. It was hidden behind a curtain. Tom Cleaver also had 700 pounds cash hidden inside his artificial lake, which he had as a result of a car crash years before. He kept his money inside the lake so that if he was ever mugged, the robber would never find it. The gatehouse was demolished and a new home is being built on the site. Five people lost their lives and were savagely murdered for a TV, a video recorder, 90 pounds cash, some alcohol, four guns, because Stevenson was pissed off he was fired from his job. In May 2001, the Home Secretary Jack Straw made a decision to increase Stevenson's minimum term from 25 years to 35 years.
史蒂文森在被带走时向陪审团微笑。房子里有一个史蒂文森和戴利兄弟错过的墙上保险箱。它藏在窗帘后面。汤姆·克利弗还在他的人造湖里藏了700英镑现金，这是他多年前车祸后的赔偿金。他把钱藏在湖里，这样如果他被抢劫，劫匪永远也找不到。 “门房”已被拆除，原址上正在建造一座新住宅。五个人失去了生命，并为了电视机、录像机、90英镑现金、一些酒精和四支枪被残忍杀害，仅仅因为史蒂文森因被解雇而感到愤怒。2001年5月，内政大臣杰克·斯特劳（Jack Straw）决定将史蒂文森的最低刑期从25年增加到35年。
Stevenson appealed this decision to the High Court, but the High Court upheld the ruling. The High Court judge described the murders as sadistic and said that three of the victims were vulnerable due to age and disability. The ruling means that Stevenson can apply for parole in 2021. John and George Dailey's sentences have expired. . There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
史蒂文森向高等法院上诉了这一决定，但高等法院维持了原判。高等法院法官将这些谋杀案描述为虐待狂行为，并指出其中三名受害者因年龄和残疾而处于弱势。该裁决意味着史蒂文森可以在2021年申请假释。约翰和乔治·戴利的刑期已经届满。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。